c'est la tradition effectivement la
sphère il agite le quai d'orsay belle
est aussi intéressante sur le fond le
figaro il revient d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
longuement sous la plume de laure
mandeville la sphère la voici en
quelques mots c'est celle de cet
ambassadeur de france hongrie qui vient
d'être recadrés après la divine la
divulgation d'un ces télégrammes
diplomatiques
on pourrait il se fait on voit ses
propos il se fait l'avocat du premier
ministre viktor orban notamment sur les
questions d'immigration
cette note aurait dû rester secrète
elles ne reflètent pas la position de la
france sur le sujet ont réagi les
autorités on regarde sur ce point
emmanuel macron c'était vendredi dernier
au sommet de bruxelles le jeu non
coopératifs et nationaliste non
seulement n'est pas digne de ce qui a
fait l'europe notre europe est née des
errements des derniers conflits mondiaux
mais il est en plus profondément
inefficace compte tenu de la réalité de
ces phénomènes migratoires
donc je désapprouve en tous points les
citations que vous ne venez de faire en
tout point elles ne correspondent
absolument rien à la position française
il s'agit maintenant d'une note dans la
nature est confidentiel et ce n'est pas
l'expression de la position officielle
française
cet ambassadeur aurait-il tenus
publiquement ses propos il aurait été
révoquée sur le champ sur la forme le
l'ambassadeur n'a pas le droit de dire
ce qu'ils pensent on veut voir qu'une
seule tête le quai d'orsay fait que je
crois que la cia il ya vraiment un
télescopage de deux choses
il ya d'une part le la position sur le
fond
or monsieur le président de la
république qui clairement qu'il est en
désaccord avec l'ambassadeur mais il dit
aussi que celui-ci il implicitement
faisait parfaitement son travail en
donnant à sa hiérarchie son opinion son
analyse problème de la circulation puis
rendu public mais ça a été rendu public
et ça c'est pas de la foi et idy très
bien qu'il ne l'a pas keating qui ne l'a
pas révoqué et là je crois qu'il ya
vraiment alors quelque chose que je
connais bien parce que je sais je vois
très bien qui est la personnalité qui va
être nommé qui est nommé ambassadeur
hongrie à la place de l'ambassadeur
actuel c'est une personne qui a été
nommé il ya trois semaines ou un mois en
conseil des ministres il n'y a
absolument aucune
je fais parce que c'est une amie à moi
et qu'elle fait actuellement sept heures
hongrois par jour depuis trois semaines
c'est pas salé à prendre en main sa mort
pour donc il ya eu coïncidence entre ce
changement d'affectation et le et cette
déclaration donc ça a été très difficile
à gérer sur le plan de la communication
par le gouvernement mais je trouve que
emmanuel macron est parfaitement dans
son dans son rôle est d'ailleurs le quai
d'orsay
c'est à peu près la position qui était
la sienne c'est nos agents en poste font
des analyses pour le gouvernement
librement en revanche ils n'ont pas
exprimé publiquement ce que damas a
précisé l'ambassadeur une position
différente de celle de la france donc
c'est vraiment une très grand malentendu
derrière tout cela mais derrière tout ça
il ya aussi le problème de fond et je
suis moi je suis d'accord avec avec au
delà de l'immigration etc
il se passe à l'est de l'europe quelque
chose de très grave
nous avons accueilli et j'ai été très
favorable cet élargissement des pays qui
ont souscrit un pacte d'adhésion aux
valeurs démocratiques et libérales je ne
crois pas qu'il puisse y avoir de
démocratie libérale
je crois que ce qui se passe en hongrie
et en pologne est actuellement très
préoccupant est que c'est peut-être le
plus grand défi que nous avons que nous
rencontrons dans la construction
européenne karine michel sur le fond
le propos de l'ambassadeur pour les
résultats caricature un peu c'est à dire
hors ban le premier ministre hongrois a
eu raison avant tout le monde sur les
migrants c'est pas nouveau en fête
sarah halifa legrand qui travaille chez
nos services étrangers l'avait rencontré
en 2015 et dès 2015 il tenait ce genre
de propos donc en effet il a le droit
d'avoir des positions et c'est même son
rôle d'avoir des positions reflétant
l'environnement où il est d'apporter
quelque chose d'autre à paris là où ça
prend un tel écho ici c'est que les
réactions des uns et des autres montre à
quel point on est entrée dans une
profonde incompréhension de ce qui se
passe dans les pays de l'est c'est à
dire que les responsables européens ne
comprennent pas ou ne veulent pas
comprendre qu' un certain nombre de
données de ces pays là qui sont passés
d'une domination soviétique à ce qu'ils
vivent comme une domination européenne
ils ont cru adhérer à quelque chose mais
finalement cela ne leur convient
peut-être pas totalement
c'est pas une maison de force salut
alors j'avais fini mais si si comment
dire si nous voulons collectivement
donner un sens à l'europe commencé en
leur disant si vous n'êtes pas content
vous n'avez qu'à partir ça dans mon
point de vue ça n'est pas la meilleure
s'il veut renoncer au pacte que vous
avez si c'est pas du tout mais pas
complaisants qui agite aujourd'hui
l'europe de l'est comme vous l'avez dit
très juste comment très justement
commence à agiter l'europe du sud à dire
que certain nombre de points qui sont
soulevées par ces pays là dans leur
contexte historique particulier qu'ils
ont été coupés pendant 50 ans de l'ouest
des migrations que bon un certain nombre
de chocs domination ottomane choix jours
doit parfaire un cours d'histoire mais
ça vient nous interroger sur un certain
nombre de questionnements et aujourd'hui
à part faire l'autruche ou leur dire de
particulier j'ai accompagné d'alcool en
vingt ans j'ai eu mal aux yeux
du comité mixte parlement européen diète
de pologne gelé président et à la fin
j'ai vu j'ai accompagné la pologne avec
des des gens formidables mazowiecki
geremek valaisanne c'était fantastique
aujourd'hui adam michnik héros martyrisé
par le le pouvoir le pouvoir communiste
on asphyxie son journal on asphyxie la
publicité on les empêche d'être livre le
la cour de justice agit en pologne c'est
extrêmement grave
ce sont des problèmes de fait on doit
réagir comment le gouvernement polonais
s'il s'agit pas du type je suis désolé
on va mis à la retraite
on amène ont baissé des choses serait
d'abord emea retraite le la moitié du
conseil koidu du conseil la cour suprême
et c'est ça veut dire que ce sont des
gens qui jugent les élections demain on
aura des élections européennes
si nous ne sommes pas contents de la
façon ça se passe c'est très grave chose
parce qu'on peut on peut avoir
l'ambassadeur il a il peut avoir comme
citoyens vivant connaissance et pays son
opinion il a il est légitime à le faire
simplement il est ambassadeur de france
donc il n'a pas à la donner il fait des
analyses publiquement mais quand il
parle à des journalistes eux mans il
fait des analyses pour le quai d'orsay
et ça l'analyse qu'il a fait est très
intéressante sur le fait de ne pas
continuer à considérer le cas au rhb
année le cas de ces cette évolution des
pays du triangle devise gradés
maintenant un peu au delà simplement de
la manière en leur disant écoutez ce que
vous faites c'est pas bien et c'est de
d'avoir un jugement d'une certaine
manière morale et de faire davantage de
politique donc là jusque là c'est très
bien sur le fond il ya un double
problème
d'abord ce que dit cet ambassadeur est
très intéressant effectivement je crois
qu'on juge et on fait beaucoup trop de
morale à la place de la politique et en
matière de politique étrangère c'est
encore pire qu'en matière de politique
intérieure si je puis dire si ça peut
être pire
or il faut les écouter les discours
dorman de viktor orban
chaque année quand les pays du triangle
devise grade se réunissent dans les
différents pays où il
alternativement ils se réunissent une
sorte de conférence il rapidement fait
il fait des discours très intéressant
parce que c'est aussi une sorte de
théoriciens or ban
c'est quelqu'un de très intéressant et
je pense qu'il faudrait davantage les
lire ici et une dernière chose l'autre
partie je vais très vite c'est que ça
déborde maintenant des pays de l'est et
du centre de l'europe
l'italie bien sûr ça a été cité mais les
pays les pays scandinaves le parti
social démocrate danois vient d'adopter
une programme une sorte de manifeste de
en renversant à 180 degrés ça sa
doctrine comme c'était le cas par
rapport aux suédois avant cette aire
d'accueil etc en dix ans maintenant si
on veut pas les suédois uniquement les
danois mais contrairement au suédois qui
continuent d'accueillir les étrangers de
stars dans une doctrine classique et
bien les danois disent le parti
social-démocrate la gauche danoise le
gouvernement dit nous ne pouvons pas
continuer à accueillir des immigrés si
nous voulons préserver notre modèle
social donc c'est pas aisément les plus
d'europe centrale
le dernier mot sur la question des
démocraties simplement simplement chacun
son tour s'il vous plaît je pense que si
la seule le les seuls mots vis-à-vis de
la hongrie de ces pays et de l'italie
c'est à disque disqualification morale
et la délégitimation politique et c'est
trop souvent le cas ces démocraties
libérales elles verseront elles
gagneront partout parce que dans cette
affaire fourni ce qui est intéressant
c'est de savoir s'ils devaient faire ou
pas faire mais l'idée que l'on puisse
nuancé le regard occidental sur or ban
n'apparaît pas comme intellectuellement
pertinente mais pourquoi pourquoi
n'est-il pas possible de se dire qu'est
ce qui explique que ces pays choisissent
des gouvernants comme ça et peut-être
qu'il faudrait qu'on se disent aussi que
les populations des opinions publiques
ces pays regarde notre modèle en disant
votre modèle a échoué votre vous avez
voulu nous donner un modèle et il a joué
avec tes allons regarder la pologne à
côté de l'ukraine
ce qu'on a fait en pologne depuis 20 ans
en plus viktor orban moi j'étais un
fanatique des viktor orban
ban ou de la pologne a fait tout
simplement je vais pas votre cas je les
jetais simplement si on fait les ouvert
jésus aimait regarder les méchants les
mêmes choses et c'est pas les méchants
et les gentils
ce sont je suis désolé c'est une
question de principe démocratique
on a adhéré ils ont adhéré librement à
un pacte qui comportait le respect d'un
certain nombre de principes auxquels on
doit être fondamentalement attachés nous
on a trahi d'autres princes en arrière à
digital
on n'a rien su l'idéologie je désirais
que le libéralisme la démocratie et le
capitalisme soit intimement liée pour
toujours est une idée d'abord
historiquement assez récente et ce n'est
pas une philosophie disons substantielle
c'est celle de l'union européenne
mais ce n'est pas une philosophie d une
substance bella établis dans des droits
fondamentaux des racines chrétiennes
quand il les revendique ils disent dans
la construction européenne elle y était
et donc dont ils ne sont pas ils
résident à ceux à ce stand de
fonctionnalités racines chrétiennes de
l'europe j'ai pas que je veux dire c'est
que l'on invoque une philosophie de
l'europe qu'ils n'ont pas et cette
philosophie et les prions mes bébés et
tout à fait craindre la charte des
droits fondamentaux
mais c'est tout mais octobre pourquoi
croyez vous qu'on a fondé l'europe
depuis 1950 sur le refus du stalinisme
sur le refus du franquisme sur leur faim
et ils ont rejoint le roi dont il était
réservé aux bourgeois de l'europe moi je
me suis engagé à relent met d'accord je
suis entièrement d'accord avec
l'élargissement je combats de 20 ans
l'idée qu'on a eu on a un cocon devait
accepter ces pays et les aider à
progresser le résultat avant pologne est
formidable ce que je donne mes pas
ces deux choses c'est qu'on déchire les
principes sur lequel cette adhésion
s'est faite et qu'on dise que l'europe
ressemble à une nouvelle forme d'union
soviétique qui serait une maison de
force
non l'europe et anne une maison libre
depuis le traité de lisbonne si on veut
en sortir les anglais le monte on en
sort si on veut y rester
on n'en respecte les principes
fondamentaux quand on a signé un contrat
on respecte le contrat ou non
et rats mais on ne fait pas les deux
choses à la fois on ne dit pas je veux
l'argent massif de l'union européenne
est en revanche ce nouveau principe les
principes auxquels j'ai adhéré
je n'en veux pas il ya un problème qui
est beaucoup plus grave scott vous ne
leur dit pas je te dis pas je ne vais
pas veulent comme ils veulent mais je
veux que la démocratie c'est quand même
oui je les ai non c'est pas moral mais
ce sont les révélations
laurent et les rôles de michel aguirre
non loin de cette émission alors je suis
votre sujet consacré sa décision on
discute pas mais vous avez raison
qu'elles peuvent vous avez raison d'être
passionnés et de l'exprimer ainsi mais
malheureusement les règles du jeu c'est
que l'émission est terminée on n'aura
même pas le temps mais ça serait ça sera
pour une autre fois aussi de parler foot
cyclisme pas de pattes point de vue de
demain pour cause de match de foot mais
vous suivrez tout ça sur figaro live
merci beaucoup beaucoup à tous les
quatre et rendez vous lundi pour un
nouveau point de vue
[Musique]